Uh, Game of Thrones is back.
Uh, or Game of Thron-es, as
we pronounce it in Los An-heles.
Uh... and everyone
has Westeros fever,
which is excitement
for the show.
It's not a sickness
where you die
while banging your twin sister.
-Uh, speaking of...
-(audience groans)
Uh, well...
She's the only one
who understands him.
Uh... Speaking of which,
uh, check out
my new favorite video game
for Game of Thrones
that I saw on reddit
the other night.
Here it is.
(Game of Thrones theme playing)
It's the 8-bit spanking
that gets me, yeah.
Oh, wow.
Oh, my God.
(cheering and applause)
-So terrible.
-Ah.
The things I do
for a high score.
Comedians, since fans are
constantly trying to figure out
what will happen next,
let's help 'em out
with some possible spoilers for
the season of Game of Thrones
that's happening right now
in 60 seconds.
And begin. Chris.
Tyrion kills Dumbledore.
Points.
Aisha.
The Fresh Prince
moves to Westeros.
Yes, points. Chris.
They finally announce the winner
of the game of thrones,
and it's Richard Hatch
from season one of Survivor.
Oh, good. Good callback.
Points. Jen.
Jon Snow's direwolf Air Bud's
his way onto a basketball team.
Points. Chris.
They reveal Westeros exists
in the mind of an autistic boy
who is immediately beheaded.
All right, points.
The St. Elsewhere ending. Jen.
Sansa just takes
a nice, quiet me day.
All right, points. Aisha.
They finally add a Black Walker,
and then it dies
in the first scene.